[Music]
this week we've got mm wonder coating
met Nick minima wrote Skyfall great song
and dead man walking taken away Tiffany
Japanese captain a damn man's like
walking to the pond
have you guys heard of this brown
coating called lime X yes know what
everything's like you can't put anything
on hydrophobic one no SELinux
I love you line the back of their trucks
and the competing brand is called a
rhino lining and it's like this thick
rubbery oh the black thing the better I
never heard it doesn't get scraped up
all that long yeah that one that one
that one yeah
so this like recently a lot of people
were making videos of them coating
certain objects with this coating the
opens up classic oh those extra ribbed
ring or what is it dot for a brace
displeasure yeah that's you don't care
your vagina - yeah I'll [ __ ] your ass up
just like that it's like to protect that
yes I made me sweat as some people are
making these videos and like just
demonstrating how durable this material
is that's good that's good more is
what's pretty social here right now
we're in a [ __ ] yeah so the way it
works is there are these two chemicals
that once they're combined it creates
this like mushy durable stuff so in
order for them to apply it onto things
they have to have like two separate
chambers and in the nozzle and then when
they spray that's when the two chemicals
ramadi recipes yeah yeah Home Depot hey
guys
minute-long where they demonstrate ah
that's cool I know that is Oh cantaloupe
oh I would've never guessed this that's
a kanima why they wasting food all the
stuff is so cool though man [ __ ]
that's a [ __ ]
whoa really
okay I believe it now whoa what I think
they're just spraying it right now Wow I
gotta have that on everything I'm gonna
put this on our freaking baby Wow just
leave knows hold on uh that's a pigeon
Wow a clay pigeon it was their droppings
that they grow very normal yeah that's
pretty strong cantaloupe a can do a line
X Carol oh you ball avocado
[Music]
how they gonna open it to eat the egg
right now is still intact inside I'm
pretty sure it's nothing
hey that's looking Oh a pressure
scrambled in there where are these other
videos that I was watching there was one
where they coated an entire watermelon
and they dropped it from my god like how
high high and once and once a drop it
was like bouncing so friggin high and
then they actually got us on and we cut
it open the watermelon was perfectly
time Wow I know the key to immortality
lining sure you cover me in that
[ __ ] right now I can't be found
at that I didn't cover me in that [ __ ]
to glue in the no holes and I did leave
that
oh yeah the mouse hole the pee hole near
home but everything else is fine I'm
indestructible except for the hole
you're going to look burnt
that's just pristine oh but I'll be able
to move either wobbly or Wiener I need
all my video just there's a hole there
hmm
so we just like spring our whole cars
with that [ __ ] then all of a it's
probably Howie what about this heavy too
yeah but the glass is still gonna break
put on your clothes and put it on a
glass
it'll be like bumper cars just bounce
bounce bounce bounce bounce bounce
bounce there's people that do Linux
their entire car though oh really
if people want to go off-roading they
like that that and that look yeah we do
the whole car like that combination try
I don't know yeah it takes a couple days
but well immediately I'll start drawing
like to fully make it rise I wonder if
it's bulletproof all this blows what is
it but it was bomb-proof
I think I'll hold it together hmm what
if you put like a lot of layers together
or maybe a lot of layers I learned like
maybe more than one coat
I'm curious I want this one everything
you know they're saying that they tested
a on the cart once they sprayed the
entire car and then they test it on like
a high-speed impact and then the hardest
balmoral 10 feet backwards the war broke
not the car ha no I didn't withstand
that but when it was like low-speed it
did with spin what the whole school I'm
not sure how fast they're going
they are also saying that light SELinux
your entire truck goes between my four
hundred and eight hundred dollars so
it's kind of pricey
it's worse than better make sure truck
that's stronger at least mm-hmm and it's
dope that everyone's experimenting and
like marketing this product is it
dangerous to spray it on your arm I'm
pretty sure okay so why are you getting
at because so like you know I get hurt
when I spot the martial arts but like
what if I spray just my chest my stomach
in my chest so you can never bend up and
down over again yeah or you can make
armor out of it put it on no but then
like I'll spray it like in sections
so it's like a turtle armor it's like
one little Anaheim little plate
yeah little plate yeah you wanted
directly on your skin why not
rip it on for you now oh yeah it doesn't
come off over time it just gets stuck
there think it was well for us it will
because we shed our skin or epidermis so
eventually I'll be will be able to peel
it off it's like when you get like an
English like super glue you know super
glue on your skin as a kid you were
trying to rip it off immediately but if
you just let it chill a couple days
it'll come up I glued my finger and my
thumb together like this and everything
was a-ok ha ha ha
I'm running into hot water crying ah
this isn't how you hungry I'm really
hungry I want a lot of food he always
want I can uh you know I want where
you're like not supposed to look and
they got sucked hmm know a game called a
nice rule so Malcolm in the Middle
that was way before then I remember it
was like a Mexican thing I don't know if
it's part of my people but I mean as a
little kid my brother was painting so
we're bored as [ __ ] let's [ __ ] punch
each other in the face how it started
like he was like you think what do I
have here then I looked me do that blah
Oh what I hated was uh punch buggy
people uh you might have to pay
attention to the goddamn Road okay stop
punching me
we used to play this game called open
chest oh I saw her to slap know we was
talking to her in the chest
oh hey don't [ __ ] know just got to
say yes I was around like this so you
would just have to it would keep you
alert all the time but it wasn't fair
because one of my friends uh it was
Reggie you're the karate champion the
[ __ ] half-life is gonna be
playing this exactly so he had like 40
[ __ ] trophies I as a kid he was
[ __ ] dope and he still competes today
this won't play open chests and blood
would come out well it would [ __ ]
hurt dude open chest I can't even stop a
clue so quick so he would hit me and it
would be like this blough I don't even
notice it until the next morning
let's first
[ __ ] that guy he was so and you know
like you would like play fight but he's
still used to keeping his guard up when
he would block your hit they would have
hurt my arm oh [ __ ] that guy did love
you Reggie [ __ ] block me please
no stop blocking bro my [ __ ] arm sir
that's what we need that for is to
protect the body on how long do is a
helmet we can spray got a helmet or just
spray your head yeah
oh you're better later dogs little
elbows they're always like yeah get up
and then there's like no more fur here
cuz I'm just making sure I'm grounded
dog calluses dog any elbow pads
oh my adorable little doggy elbows happy
people always a nice hipster thing I bet
Gargi oh you didn't care come on 99 yeah
alright for our next story there's this
fourteen-year-old girl that was [ __ ]
around on a gondola ride and why she
[ __ ] around
err economist oh all those things oh the
boat yeah by Venus unveils calls gondola
yeah and what does it blank are
something to guys like that
well the green one work almost looking
part organ donor because our houses now
this took place at Six Flags Great
Escape in New York and I'm going to show
you the video and so no no no so she's
all survived awesome yeah so what
happened was that's all gone a [ __ ] cuz
it's crazy
maybe she should have died not important
I don't matter stupidity does Darwinism
okay do you would have been dead it's no
longer those I wasn't stupid I was just
carrying but go on your way sympathy
take it away Julia yeah so what happened
was a she was on the drive with her
brother and witnesses were saying that
this little girl she kept sticking out
her leg to try to hit branches as like
she was why not writing the right okay
okay they got longer
yeah actually doing that in so I I guess
at one point like she stretched out a
little too far and that's when she
flipped out and so uh why don't we say
Mel cares okay okay she does she doesn't
have to die she
a woman yeah you don't wanna 14 funerals
enough to know yeah freshman to this
freshman a little day little girl
no hey fine so she's a grown-ass woman
had a fourteen years old
in Czechoslovakia she is she should have
four kids by now yeah sure sorry
she was dangling 25 feet up in the air
and so the video I'm about to show you
guys is where there's a rabbit a crowd
of people right under her knee and it's
laughing uh-oh
the Connor know things that are
suffering oh she shouldn't died not so
lucky she shouldn't die she was just
learning it life for the movie oh I love
how the guy on the phone is like alright
y'all catch up y'all chatter that's
[ __ ] crazy she created her own blend
does she think um I'm not sure it was
not reported if she fainted or not but
they do report that they did they took
her to a hospital
well the cool thing is that it wasn't
that high so it is she felt you to live
here that's [ __ ] scary just broke
like eight bones what did we learn
don't be stupid I think if I was one of
the guys at the bottom I'll catch you
I'll catch you in the last round - come
fast because I pretty sure if I'll let
that nobody will try to catch me haha
like yo somebody catch me - like nah
I'll be on the floor like the [ __ ]
Acme clock probably I want to clear out
everybody clear out doesn't be a big
splash greater than rings wait why are
you calling the janitors cuz we got to
clean this [ __ ] up she look like she's
best this way yeah her necklace tuck is
small oh good Dean I know because more
people are willing to catch it ya know
what what would be a pleasure of her
touching trees with her feet she's just
[ __ ] around
I don't know after Fela yeah I remember
being that age a year ago but that's a
good guy behavior like always are like
explorative girls are dumb - I know this
[ __ ] idiot grown freshman year should
pierce their own tongue with a needle oh
right you a ninja pass out their sister
founders but that's not as gangsters
like what guys do they like roll around
they'll try to kick [ __ ] try to fight
stuff it's a different time now women
are standing up there and they're do PR
yeah they want to be like men I'm gonna
do stupid [ __ ] like that now we're all
equal yeah I like that
I didn't just strange that she's 14
doing it exactly the 14 the one that I
know is like the cashing outside girl
like like that agency you're too cool
you're too cool like this is like some
seven year old behavior yeah for me this
is just strange that she's like 14 I do
here right now it's crazy I try to touch
leaves with my feet if I was on the
gondola - I'd be like oh you're not -
I'm still going to sorting and then
[ __ ] rocking it back and forth hey
you let's just do this let's take the
thing off NoHo so scary I know I love
hello didn't we go into first one
together and we kept trying - singing
you're really freaking out yes I was
attached to the floor I'm so scared this
woman were egging me on
I could not my object nervous just
thinking about me in the Las Vegas one
where it's [ __ ] massive oh yeah that
one - it's just
enclosed but then it just feels so open
it scares the [ __ ] out of me I can't I
can't status here yeah it's pretty cool
when you're sitting down in your time
holding the bench like this and I'm
looking out suddenly it's so beautiful
you know what I get into rides at
Disneyland I like use up all the space
so I first grab the bar and it's sturdy
then I flare out my elbow so you're
touching everything so I have I'm stuck
this way and I'm stuck this way and then
I try to push my knees out to some stuff
this way and I flex my butt cheeks and
put my heel there so that way I'm stuck
everywhere right
I like how to write the theme park is
Disneyland that is crazy
you didn't want to try I'm fortunate
like this poop fell down everyone there
like it face together I thought that I
was doing it like this yeah I was like
yeah like this like happens like it on
me I'm employed I like any of those
roller coasters now I'm top-heavy
I'll [ __ ] fly off dude then you start
going back down oh I'm hoping one day
someone offers you like a complete
offices hello my name is offered an
exorbitant of money to go skydiving I'm
somewhat the millions you know night
probably still say no you wouldn't you
love money to millions on the millions
to ride the stratosphere in Vegas focus
angle to the side alright a skydiver
direction really I've been on some [ __ ]
like that like you know in Taiwan they
have to build up to tell us small so a
lot of the amusement parks are on top of
skyscrapers it's [ __ ] scary [ __ ]
so it'll be like a [ __ ] forty forty
floor building and then the Disney lands
on top so a lot of roller coasters are
[ __ ] dangling off in [ __ ] [ __ ] that I
grew up on my sister's case no man it's
the money if the bag of money is written
from you can see what I mean if my mom
came up to issues like David just take
the money I probably do it but I
guarantee you are passing out like I'm
almost I like you would rather suck a
dick first didi be harmful you do it all
the time yes perfected it's easy do if
somebody was like dude if you suck my
dick right now I'll give you [ __ ]
five hundred thousand dollars before he
finishes that sentence i'm already
unbuckled append click-clack click-clack
click-clack
nobody please [ __ ] button-fly jeans
haha here's a thing but in the hotel
room in fly's open
million dollars one slide
IOP on the [ __ ] onesie dude I could
just pick a death like this I want that
you know the videos are like they have
um it's a slingshot and you have videos
people screaming I want a video like the
view so yeah no bad cause where they go
ah yeah what is it
ah it has to be a good amount of money
though cuz I was approached by a very
affluent company that everybody knows to
go skydiving to do a campaign about
being brave and they heard videos of
mine that I'm very very much going to
hide so they wanted me to parachute and
it was a good amount of money and I said
no and they raised it up again and I
said no they raise it up again I said no
so they got another influence to do it
for like literally like 10% of my dinner
to give me yeah because the
entertainment was the fact I'm so
[ __ ] scared yeah it's got somebody
ops do to enjoy it and that person told
me was like yeah they approached me to
give me this okay that's funny because I
got like literally 100% I saw the video
that he did it was boring as [ __ ]
because they weren't scared yeah they're
excited like this is gonna be a grace
because wow this is awesome
made of it a little bit just that god I
love that video oh that's so bad yeah if
you guys come to LA there's a mountain
called Echo Mountain it's based at the
last quarter mile of it it's the road is
as wide as this table and then you just
fall off and die so I didn't I didn't
know that and so my brother told me that
I could do this and my tea was pretty
tired like four or five miles up and
when we got to the last quarter mile I
got so scared I ran back down into this
area where there was shaded trees and I
just stayed there and I waited for for
an hour to go to the top and come back
down I could do it I would I went far
enough I could do that our last story
there was this man that believed his son
was dead because the county told him hey
we had every son here
you know you're done by the body No so
he asked look who's there and he asked
like hey should I come over and identify
the body and they said no you don't get
to come because we already identified
him through fingerprints so he believed
that his 57 year old son had passed away
Paul is this guy like 95 he's 82 well
he's an old man his heart still weak
already yeah and so the entire family
spent $20,000 on a funeral for a man
that wasn't Oh 11 days later they got a
phone call saying like hey your son is
standing on my front door like you know
he's he doesn't like can you pick up
your son she's like trying to fight
pigeons right now so what was away was
what was it dude he was just one which
one McDonald's like what happened so
this guy he was actually homeless and he
has mental issues that the son oh they
believe they found out that this man
that they were claiming was the son like
they believe him they believe the county
cuz they're like well if someone's
telling me this is like my son like I'm
not going to question it so Antonio
how did his fingerprint match up with a
homeless guy so that's the thing there
was a lot of fuck-ups in the county so
now the family is going to be suing the
course what what county is this the
county is funny Alfred you clear Orange
County on a sec it though what this is a
little weird for me just because of oh
maybe so it's his son he has a mental
condition but the father is living okay
and the other guy's homeless didn't want
to be in home sometimes we want to be
who was yeah so very cool so this family
says this Frank senior and these are
just three kids and so Frank jr. is the
one that he believed had passed so
they're saying that he refuses help
she doesn't launder any shelter we want
any money he doesn't want anything from
his family home I know I like to suck a
dick for sandwiches you can't stop my
dreams yeah yeah but they're saying like
it was really traumatic and that Frank
jr. so this is like the area where they
found the
unidentified man and so-and-so Frank jr.
sister came to the site put his photo
there put some flowers but she think it
was a really traumatic scene because
they were on dirty blankets and blood on
the floor she purposely put out a blurry
picture yeah what about David Hasselhoff
maybe that was the only one that they
hadn't yeah and so this is Frank jr. he
looks a little bit at them he's like a
retired wait older than his dad Wow 80
something 82 that's amazing Wow yeah the
reason was they ended up burying some
stranger and I'm like they're saying it
was so traumatic they're like I married
my brother like they don't like he
doesn't understand the trauma at the
family were like why are you get trippin
about and Heat's on going back to Street
you home people are crazy
mama be homeless I'd be so pissed also
what I die can you guys like make sure
notes on how much money I don't think I
am second I'm on I don't even okay don't
worry about that [ __ ] dude you don't
even have to say it we're actually you
can put you in a toilet and flush you
down levy making debug it we'll miss you
with the goldfish I never saw those
funeral processions like just come on
mill they're dead I feel like funerals
are worth more than weddings yes really
a hundred percent agree G they're worth
more than weird like people find more
money the cost more no I mean like I
think to remand the money on someone's
funeral it's worth more than the wedding
because the wedding is more like well
the couples probably have to pay for it
and then there's a future that they
probably should be spending that money
on a home or something else or they may
not last
yeah but then we're kind of like
celebrating someone's entire lifetime
and then I'm sure you're usually not
gonna have a second one my mom says is
that that one too you might as well
they're not going to a funeral divorce
you know
in this case you're going to have a
second to true true my mom doesn't want
to get gross cremated yeah you didn't
wanted to deep-fries she don't wanna be
roasted anymore she wants to be a
steamed
she must be buried now gray-haired and
smoked buried yeah she wants to bury
know what kind of life I want everyone I
just want something very simple just eat
me all that does look at growth bro hope
you guys enjoyed that video but if you
didn't guess what you can directly
contribute to the articles that we
discussed just cruise on over to the
description box below click on that link
to submit your article also for the next
video click right up hey
[Music]
[Music]